welcome to my review of The Legend of
Zelda Ocarina hey listen you're adorable
but freaking annoying watch out I found
something I'm so excited what is this
The Legend of Zelda the Ocarina of Time
is widely regarded as perhaps the best
video game ever made and you guys know
me I don't get into lists and all that
stuff it is amazing it came out for the
Nintendo 64 which is my favorite video
game system of all time countless
imitations I mean there are so many
adventure games similar to this one
where characters are roaming giant vast
worlds and there's so many different
lands and levels and puzzles and
characters and everything and it set the
bar for each Zelda installment after
that and I think one of the most
remarkable things about this game is
that the main character never speaks all
you hear is John pipe and stuff like
that from from link and you love this
little guy and because of that you sense
such a courageousness in this kid such a
bold fearlessness that he has to try to
save his little world the plot of the
game is similar to Mario you know
there's a princess and she's in danger
and there's a evil guy Bowser you know
he's out he's out to destroy the world
and everything this one it's length
evil guys Ganon and Princess Zelda and
her world is enslaved and you know
Stiebel crap is starting to happen and
young little link you grow up with this
kid throughout the game he gets older
and older older and you just feel you're
just like you are link in this game the
gameplay is just there is no comparison
to certain adventure games the controls
it's very easy to figure out it feels so
natural when you're using it also one of
the things this game is not afraid to be
is very challenging there are some
levels in this game that will make you
hate your life burn water temple I love
the character of the owl he's so awesome
he just shows up he's like hey you don't
really know what you're doing right now
do you well you know what I'm going to
help you should go over there I'm not
really going to tell you where but you
should probably go in that direction and
maybe look for something I can't really
tell you what because I would give away
too much but I'm going to give you a
little hint okay mm-hmm just little hint
but when you do beat some of these
levels and figure out some of the
puzzles it's so vindicating it just it's
great Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time by
far one of the best video games ever
created when you start playing this game
it's hard to put it down you'll get into
the characters it'll make you want to
play the other Zelda games
it's
a brilliant game I know the 3d version
is out right now it apparently it's
pretty good too antenna 64 men good
memories
you